ici nous allons prêt à l'action Shawn a souligné
que le krav maga allait être le
style de basse pour les combats Brahma God n'est pas un
sport, il est destiné à neutraliser et
désarmer, il est conçu spécifiquement pour le
combat rapproché, c'est un
personnel de combat très très efficace faisant les
armes  dans une autre forme d'arme, les
balles sont sorties, alors
gardons le pistolet accroché, vous ne le perdrez jamais dans
ce cas, vous savez que nous l'avons transformé en un
poing américain, il est toujours bon d'y ajouter
cette belle saveur Ganic de poids
aussi  J'aime faire ressortir le
réalisme et un salut granuleux que vous voulez que
ce soit un peu différent à chaque
fois qu'il y a beaucoup d'acteurs mais c'est
différent un super physique il y aura
un conflit physique dans ce film c'est
une action dramatique mais sur  mon nom
dans la section l'action n'est qu'un
sous-produit de l'histoire et tout se
gélifie vraiment très bien